γενήθηκα με τημουσική γεννήθηκα με το τραγούδι πήρα πάρα πολλα μαθήματα από τον ιλία τουν
τρόπου πρου σκέπτεται στον τρόπο που δουλεύει και τα λίπ πάντα θόρι πως βεβαίως θε
πούλησαν συνεγάλε σταύρο υπάρχει να περιστατικό το οποίο θυμάσει με χρη σήμερα μου λέ υπάρτειο
γιατί θα κάνο κλίν αν ερχόταν ένα ακόμα και εκανε πρότασει στο σταύρον πως σταντίνου
να βρίσκε στο ψυφοδέλτιμο θα το έκανω σταύροκστακαι αρχίσανα τρέχω να ξεφύγο μακρία πως ναναπιπηλέσε
μεκιλι άλλο έναντα ένα λα ευπότκα σήμερα μαζί σας τρίνι του πάσχα και επόμε να
αφήσουμε για λίγο πίσω τις πολιτικές συζητήεις τις οικονομικές και όλα αυτά να δούμε κάτι
διαφορετικό μαζί μας ο σταύρος κονσταντίνου για να δούμε την μπορεία του ταόμορφα πράγματα που
ακούμε ότι έρχονται και πολλά άλλα σταύρομου ε ευχαριστώ πολύ ο αποδέχθηκες να είσε σήμερα
μαζί μου ησέα μου είναι μεγάλη μουτιμή καταρχή γιατις φίλος μου χρόνια και καταδεύτερο γιατί
αυτό το πότηκας που κάνεις και αυτή την προσπάθεια την εκτιμού πάρα πολίτη θα υμάζω
έχω οδεί όλα τα πρώτικα να σε κανατα τυργός και είναι μεγάλη μουτιμή που έρχουμε
να κάνω ένα πρέι ε πιο σοβαρά πότκ να πούμε λίγη κουβεντούλα θέλω να καθέτα
ισόψυχά μας σε κινούμε από το βάσικα πύρες μάθηματα σταύρα από αυτό το χώρο καθημερινά
περνώμαθήματα και καθημερινά χαίρομε που παίρνω και μαθματα είτε καλά είται κακά γιατί ατά αυτό
βελτιώνο το χαρακτήρα μας νομίζω ότι ένας άνθρωπος ο οποίος θα ήταν όλα ρόδινα μπροστά
του δεν θα εξελιζόταννα πάνουμε λίγο τα πράγματα από την αρχή πως μπήκε η μουσική
στης ζωή του σταύρου και πως βρέθηκε ο σταύρος σήμερα ναεστις γές μα ζωές ημουσική
νομίζω ότι μπήκε διαχύρος θεού στη ζωή μου γεννίή